al momento de hablar de economía en
france24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida
a mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
empezamos en eeuu porque el gobierno
logró evitar su cierre cuéntenos así con
el congreso ese país aprobó una
iniciativa de ley para frenar lo que
parecía un inminente cierre del gobierno
y financiarlo hasta el 3 de diciembre
aunque andrés esto sólo es un respiro
mientras los partidos políticos
continúan el debate sobre cómo aumentar
el límite de endeudamiento del gobierno
antes de que ese país se arriesgue a
incumplir su deuda lo que tendría graves
consecuencias en la economía para este
año se estima que el gobierno de ese
país incurrirá en unos gastos de 58
billones de dólares y tendrá 3.5
billones de ingresos lo que dejaría un
déficit de 2,3 billones de dólares según
la oficina de presupuesto del congreso
la aprobación de hoy dará a los
legisladores más tiempo para diseñar
medidas de gasto que permitan financiar
a las agencias federales y los programas
de administración el centro de políticas
bipartidistas ha dicho que el gobierno
federal probablemente no cumpla con el
40 por ciento de los pagos adeudados en
las siguientes semanas
aunque el tesoro ha tomado medidas para
conservar el efectivo cuando se termine
se verá obligado a defender a depender
de los ingresos para pagar sus
obligaciones que incluyen pagos a los
beneficiarios del seguro social veterano
funcionarios públicos y personal militar
porque ahora pasamos a cuba porque se
autorizó la creación de empresas
privadas cómo es esto bueno la isla
anunció hoy que autorizó a las primeras
35 mil pymes luego de la aprobación de
varias normativas que les permite
constituirse como persona jurídica para
ejercer sus actividades económicas en
este primer grupo de empresas incluye 32
mil pymes privadas y tres estatales ahí
figuran 13 dedicadas a la producción de
alimentos 6 se manufactura 3
relacionadas con actividades de
reciclaje y otras 3 desarrolladas en el
parque científico y tecnológico de la
habana de estas empresas
andrés 20 son una reconversión de
actividades que ya existían y se
conocían como trabajadores por cuenta
propia mientras que los restantes son
nuevos entes económicos en agosto pasado
cuba aprobó ocho decretos con los que
reconoce legalmente las empresas
privadas aunque bajo ciertas
restricciones y control estatal jorge el
desempleo neón europea bajó en agosto
bueno continúa la tendencia a la baja a
medida que la economía se va recuperando
con todo este tema de la pandemia del
cobi 19 el desempleo promedio en los 27
países del bloque europeo y bajó
levemente al 6,8 por ciento en el octavo
mes del año eso quiere decir andrés que
todavía hay 14,5 millones de
desempleados pero lo que realmente
preocupa es la tasa de desempleo juvenil
que en toda la zona es del 16,2 por
ciento pero en españa y en grecia
superan el 30 por ciento y son los más
altos de toda la zona tanto en el
desempleo juvenil como la tasa en
general mientras que dinamarca y
alemania tienen bajas tasas de
desocupación en general entre el 3 y el
4% pero la tasa de jóvenes desocupados
se duplica y
y luego de la cancelación por la
pandemia dubai inaugura ahora su expo
mundial así es un año después
literalmente dubai estreno hoy el primer
evento de este tipo en lo que ya
conocemos y hablamos como la era del
cobi 19 la expo dubai también celebra
este año el 50 aniversario de la
creación de los emiratos árabes unidos-
la extravagancia futurista se demostró
en la ceremonia realizada en lo que
parece una nueva ciudad que fue
construida sobre lo que alguna vez
fueron dunas de arenas en las afueras de
dubai dubai invirtió 7 mil millones de
dólares en la creación de este el lugar
que estará abierto por seis meses de
esta forma no hay esperas atraer nuevas
empresas y extranjeros para que compren
propiedades en el centro comercial de
los emiratos árabes unidos- jorge
momento de conocer los indicadores bueno
vamos con eso wall street cerró negativo
en un mes movido por la crisis de ever
ground y el techo de la deuda de eeuu
así como la persistente alta inflación
en ese país en europa los principales
mercados cayeron por la crisis en el
sector
energético y las dudas de wall street y
en américa latina' reino cierta
estabilidad tras el acuerdo en el senado
de eeuu y cuál es nuestra cifra del día
la cifra del día andrés son 233 mil
lugares en reino unido que son afectados
por el cierre de otras tres compañías de
energía debido al alza en los precios
del gas natural desde principios de
agosto al menos diez empresas de
servicio público en ese país han
quebrado o recortado con la formación
económica muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en france 24 ustedes
también muchas gracias quédense con toda
nuestra programación
y
[Música]